summer is right around the corner and
for summer school students help is on
the way the Clark County School District
once again offering transportation to
after school programs at the Boys and
Girls Clubs across the Valley 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough checked out
the one of the nine locations that's
going to be offering after school care
and she joins us now live from CCSD
headquarters with the details Madison
yeah Denise this is part of ccsd's
Summer acceleration program it's really
a great resource for parents and
students as parents say the lack of
Transportation has been going on ever
since covet hit about three years ago
after school I don't have to worry about
them so much John pembleton pleased that
his son Elijah has the boys and girls
club to go to after school just gives
them something to do it just you know
keeps them out of trouble keeps them
focused it keeps them one to come back
and now the Clark County School District
has announced it's bringing back
transportation for its students to nine
of their after-school care locations as
part of their summer acceleration
program
director of Clubhouse operations
realizes the important void they fill
for families it's super crucial that
kids have a place to go whether it's
after school or during the summer when
there's breaks
oh we have different programs that
reinforce what the kids are learning in
the schools we provide a fun safe place
for them to be that way parents can work
knowing that their kids are taken care
of fed Kendra Anderson and her
granddaughter Kaden relieved that
transportation is being offered again
this summer Caden looks forward to her
time here sometimes we have like
fail chips and like we have lots of fun
and Grandma Kendra welcomes the help as
far as a time it will give me more time
you know I don't have to rush
27 district schools will benefit from
these bus services servicing nine
different Boys and Girls Clubs across
the valley for more information on the
schools being serviced we'll have a list
up on our website at 8newsnow.com
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now